قالت وزارة الدفاع الإماراتية إنها
اعترضت صاروخا
باليستيا أطلقه المتمردون الحوثيون اليمنيون المدعومون من إيران ، وقالت
إن شظايا
ذلك الصاروخ سقطت خارج
مناطق سكنية لذلك لم ترد
أنباء عن وقوع إصابات أو أضرار
ووقت قصير.  بعد ذلك
نشرت وزارة الدفاع مقطع فيديو لما قالت
إنها ضربة نفذتها استهدفت
موقع إطلاق ذلك
الصاروخ الباليستي في اليمن حيث قالت
إنها دمرت موقع الإطلاق هذا الآن
يأتي خلال تلك الزيارة التاريخية
للرئيس الإسرائيلي إلى  وقال متحدث
رئاسي الإماراتي لشبكة CNN إن الرئيس هيرزوغ والوفد المرافق له لم
يتعرضوا لأي خطر وأن هذه الزيارة
مستمرة كما هو مخطط لها ، وهذه ثالث
هجوم أو محاولة هجوم نفذها
المتمردون الحوثيون على الإمارات
هذا الشهر في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر.
قُتل عمال أجانب
في هجوم صاروخي وطائرة مسيرة ، وفي
الأسبوع الماضي اعترضت الولايات المتحدة والقوات الإماراتية
صاروخا باليستيا عطا  ck التي كانت
تستهدف القاعدة الجوية بالقرب من أبو ظبي
الآن حذر الحوثيون من أن هذه
ستكون حملة مستمرة
كما يسمونها يريدون
أن تنهي الإمارات مشاركتها في الحرب في
اليمن.
نحن نرى هذا التصعيد في
الصراع هناك سواء كان القتال
على الأرض أو الضربات الجوية التي
ينفذها التحالف الذي تقوده السعودية
بالطبع الإمارات العربية المتحدة عضو رئيسي في ذلك
التحالف الذي تقوده السعودية الآن يبقى السؤال هنا
حول مدى تورط إيران  في كل هذا
أه سواء كان لديها أي علم مسبق أو
إذا أعطت الضوء الأخضر
لوكيلها المتمردون الحوثيون لتنفيذ هذه
الهجمات على الإمارات لأن هذا
يأتي في وقت
نرى فيه هذه المنطقة تتجه
نحو دي  - التصعيد على
جبهات عديدة ومختلفة مع المحادثات الدبلوماسية
بين الإمارات العربية المتحدة والمملكة العربية
السعودية وإيران العلاقات بين رجلين وأيضًا المحادثات
بين إيران والغرب نحو
اتفاق نووي يبدو أنه
يمضي قدمًا وهذا السعي.  على
بقايا ألمانيا لم يتم الرد عليها سي إن إن اسطنبول